[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para seguir el desarrollo
de la copa américa y la eurocopa estos
son nuestros titulares
brasil y colombia protagonizan un choque
de alto vuelo en la copa américa la
canarinha defiende su puntaje perfecto
ante los cafeteros que cierran su
participación en la fase de grupos y
necesitan al menos un punto para
garantizar su clasificación
inglaterra croacia y república checa son
los clasificados a octavos de final del
grupo t en la eurocopa los tres leones
vencieron por la mínima a los checos que
perdieron el segundo lugar a mano de los
water nick quienes derrotaron tres a una
escocia analizamos el cierre de este
grupo
y también se cierra el grupo de la
muerte con un partidazo portugal se
juega a su suerte ante francia con la
necesidad de sumar de al menos sumar
para no complicarse al mismo tiempo
alemania choca con hungría tenemos
informe desde portugal
como cada día le damos la bienvenida a
nuestro analista sana castro directora
del diario hace de colombia la
bienvenida un gusto federico estamos
viviendo jornadas muy emocionantes en
ambos torneos si empezamos con la copa
américa porque tras el descanso del
martes se reanuda la actividad del grupo
b con la penúltima fecha y dos duelos de
gran importancia en el primer turno
ecuador y perú juegan un mano a mano
vital para las posibilidades de ambos
partidos que también mira de reojo
venezuela y el plato fuerte lo
protagonizan brasil que pone en juego su
imbatibilidad ante colombia que cierra
la fase de grupos y con al menos un
punto asegura su clasificación sobre
este partido habla el seleccionador
brasileño ti te ves no sus
enfrentamientos contra colom de fórum
simple nuestros partidos contra colombia
siempre son difíciles y se lo dije a los
jugadores
[Música]
si miramos atrás tanto en el amistoso
como en las eliminatorias siempre nos
exigen a nuestro máximo nivel silver
mines auto nivel de eficiencia
para ti te anticipa un partido
complicado ante colombia como
históricamente él dice han sido que que
sabemos en lo que planea reinaldo rueda
para frenar a este temible brasil lo
primero era que reinaldo rueda de la
selección colombia esperaba a llegar a
este partido con mucha más tranquilidad
haber solucionado la clasificación en
los partidos anteriores él no quiso
hablar mucho del sistema es decir el
esquema con el que partirá el
posicionamiento de sus jugadores en el
campo de juego pero si hablo de un
concepto y este concepto es la tenencia
de la pelota o mejor evitar que brasil
tenga la pelota para que le pueda hacer
daño a colombia ahora lo que esperamos
es ver en dónde va a presionar colombia
en qué zona del campo intentar cortar
ese circuito de juego del equipo de type
que está muy bien aceitado que tiene
mucho tiempo de trabajo sin duda vamos a
ver un partido muy interesante y en el
que por fin se va a probar si la idea de
rueda ya ha calado en el equipo y
también por su parte en la conferencia
de prensa anticipó que planea rotar
jugadores como lo viene haciendo es un
lujo que se puede dar brasil este
derrotar y que no se resienta el
rendimiento esa es la palabra correcta
es un lujo porque primero brasil tiene
muchas variantes tienen
nombres importantes que pueden sustituir
incluso a los que son llamados titulares
pero además brasil ha logrado algo que
es muy difícil y muy importante y es
cambiar nombres sin que el esquema o sin
que la idea de juego varíe es decir el
engranaje del equipo diferente o sea a
partir de los nombres no va a cambiar y
brasil va a ser la misma incluso con
otras figuras en el campo cerramos de
momento este capítulo de copa américa
porque la principal acción del día pasa
por la eurocopa empezamos con lo que
dejó el martes que se cerró el grupo d
con tres clasificados inglaterra venció
por la mínima república checa y aseguró
el primer lugar y croacia venció 3 a 1 a
escocia para conseguir el segundo puesto
los chicos están clasificados a su vez
como uno de los mejores terceros salas y
vemos en la primera ronda de inglaterra
cumplió sumó siete puntos dos goles a
favor ninguno en contra pero no se ha
visto nada brillante entonces como se
evalúa esta primera ronda del equipo de
shaw de clasifica con un gol de sterling
que creo que puede ser el símbolo del
juego de esta selección inglaterra juega
bien pero no es constante ataca con
alegría con muchas
pero también deja muchos espacios no
logra convencer aunque por ejemplo no ha
aparecido pero cuando hay talento
siempre hay luz y esto define partidos
pero es que del medio hacia adelante no
sólo hablamos de kane hablamos de saca
de raiford de folder de sancho es decir
la cantidad de talento con la que cuenta
south gate es muy importante vamos a ver
qué ajustes hace desde lo táctico es
sobre todo en tema defensivo para
enfrentar nada más y nada menos que al
segundo del grupo de la muerte o sea que
ya de allí anticipamos un partidazo en
octavos de final si se viene un cruce
fuerte que también pondrá a prueba a
inglaterra por otro lado croacia ha
revivido con una contundente victoria
para meterse en el segundo puesto el
seleccionador el acto dálits se refirió
a la clasificación
sin nada fue un gran partido tuvimos el
control y nunca perdimos la cabeza donde
lo logró
controla mantuvimos la pelota en el piso
contra un oponente que es incómodo en
los balones largos y muy agresivo
lanzando un auto más pesca que emigre
esa agresión
y ondas modernas no fue fácil fue muy
duro especialmente después de estos 10
días llenos de presión locura y todo lo
demás creo en mi polvo una suegro y
peter que usamos casi monacal luego esto
todo lo demás en lo que se refería a la
leche fueron críticas de la prensa a
filtraciones e incluso rumores de un
potencial despidos y quedado eliminada
de croacia en este caso como como se
entiende este triunfo es un
resurgimiento del subcampeón del mundo
este segmento yo lo quiero llamar luka
modric
y es que luka modric es la prueba de que
los genios de que los diferentes son
interminables y que tiene fútbol para
seguir escribiendo su leyenda e historia
hasta donde quiera yo creo que además de
ese golazo que marcó con el externo que
ya es su marca registrada y aunque esté
croacia no logra tener el nivel de rusia
2018 lo que sí vemos es que tiene la
experiencia
el espíritu y sobre todo el talento de
jugadores más allá de modric como
perisic y vlasic que ya empiezan a verse
como el futuro de esta selección de
croacia creó hace llegó para competir se
clasificó segunda y seguro a seguir
dando emociones en esta euro por otra
parte de este miércoles se cierra la
fase de grupo son de la eurocopa y se
define el mapa definitivo de los octavos
de final hay 11 de 16 clasificados pero
sólo dos cruces confirmados en la
próxima ronda italia ante austria y
gales dinamarca en estos momentos se
está definiendo el grupo en españa que
se juega a su suerte ante eslovaquia se
impone ya 3 a 0 y empieza a encaminar su
clasificación y suecia le está ganando
por la mínima 1 a 0 a polonia que de
momento decepciona y queda en el último
lugar también se cierra el grupo efe el
grupo de la muerte con los duelos entre
alemania hungría y portugal ante francia
este último juego es crucial para
portugal el último campeón europeo desde
ese país
nuestra corresponsal daniela zambrano
nos cuenta cómo esperan este encuentro
portugal defina hoy su futuro en la
eurocopa 2020 tras este encuentro con
transparencia previsto para las 8 de la
noche ahora portugal en budapest cuál es
el ambiente en el país no es el más
idóneo para las celebraciones por causa
de la pandemia y mayores restricciones
en la capital por ejemplo está prohibida
la instalación de pantallas en sitios
públicos para evitar aglomeraciones pero
aún así los ciudadanos pueden acudir a
los comercios que han dispuesto
pantallas en sus establecimientos para
disfrutar este partido en familia por
ejemplo los que se encuentran a mi
espalda ya los dueños nos han comentado
que prácticamente tienen todas las mesas
reservadas para poder ver este partido
los escenarios posibles para portugal es
que de ganar clasifica a octavos de
final de empatar o perder incluso por
dos goles también podría estar
clasificado siempre y cuando hungría no
venza a alemania el mensaje que ha
difundido el capitán de la selección
cristiano ronaldo a través de las redes
sociales crean tanto como nosotros vamos
con todo es más o menos el sentir de los
seguidores del fútbol en el país si se
puede vencer a francia se hizo en el
2016 en la eurocopa sin embargo
coinciden en que será un partido duro
difícil
está claro que las posibilidades de
portugal no están seriamente
comprometidas a estos resultados que se
están dando ahora también le dan cierto
colchón incluso puede perder con francia
y clasificar igualmente pero las dudas
que se le han puesto al campeón europeo
en su rendimiento hacen que este partido
tenga otro otro enfoque para fernando
santos claro es que el antecedente
cercano que tenemos ese partido donde
contra alemania en el que quedó claro
que las coordinaciones defensivas de
portugal no están muy aceitadas y sobre
todo que no ha logrado generar esa
presencia en el mediocampo ni bernardo
silva ni carvalho incluso han aparecido
y creo que ese duelo ahí con poco va a
ser fundamental pero qué pasa está
cristiano ronaldo está cristiano ronaldo
que seguramente intentará aprovechar la
banda de pagar que se lo vio con un poco
de dudas en el anterior partido y este
es el partido 178 de ronaldo con su
selección y siempre logra marcar esa
diferencia no ya lleva tres goles en
este torneo creo que va a ser un partido
muy interesante que también va a poner a
prueba a francia que viene de un empate
ante hungría es decir se dieron cuenta
que son que pueden frenarlo
ese camino por el título llegando como
los grandes favoritos y es que está de
francia de suele adaptarse a sus rivales
puede que suba la vara hoy un poquito en
su rendimiento al tener enfrente un
equipo como portugal de acuerdo parece
que ellos a veces quieren que el otro
equipo tenga el control del partido y
luego ellos aceleran para generar ese
daño en el campo rival hemos visto como
es fundamental ese mediocampo con cante
y pop y por supuesto el desequilibrio
que puede generar mbappe va a ser muy
importante los movimientos que logra ser
griezmann para abrir espacios y
seguramente hacerle daño esta defensa de
portugal de la que ya hablamos se le
vieron muchas inconsistencias en el
partido contra alemania te pido
brevemente una línea sobre este alemania
hungría que también define este grupo
bueno hungría es uno de los equipos que
más ha batallado ha puesto en problemas
a todos los equipos es un equipo que
sabe que siendo sólido atrás puede
generar problemas tiene un portero que
tiene de las mejores atajadas del torneo
así que alemania que ya demostró contra
portugal lo que puede hacer pasando de
una posesión casi que insulsa a hacer
mucho daño con química o con goes en
clic son jugadores que entran
en el área creo que va a ser un partido
interesante probando estos dos estilos
perfecto vamos a repasar ahora otras
novedades vinculadas a estos dos torneos
alcaldía de múnich enarboló la bandera
arcoiris antes de alemania hungría en
apoyo a los derechos el eje vete
amenazados por una nueva ley en hungría
la uefa defendió su decisión de no
permitir la iluminación del estadio
allianz-arena y su presidente alexander
se spring calificó a la iniciativa de
múnich de populista
el capitán de bolivia marcelo moreno
martins se reintegró a los
entrenamientos tras haber superado el
hobbit 19 junto al delantero también se
sumaron louis el hacking y en henry y
back a los tres están en perfecto estado
de salud
arturo vidal cuestiona los rumores que
circularon sobre la vibración de la
burbuja sanitaria en chile' el
mediocampista aseguró que deberían
apoyar a la selección y no inventar
cosas como que no son vida ni otros
jugadores sin cumplieron protocolos al
permitir el ingreso de un peluquero
muchas gracias por acompañarnos en esta
nueva edición de diario de copas muchas
gracias ahora por estar con nosotros y a
ustedes continúen en france24 in france
24 punto com